canadians appear to be nearly split when
it comes to protests having an influence
and loosening pandemic restrictions and
ips's poll exclusive to global news
conducted after police enforcement began
in ottawa shows 54 percent of canadians
believe the nationwide trunk or protest
had at least some effect on provincial
government's easing restrictions the
majority of canadians disapprove of how
justin trudeau handled the protest with
57 percent not happy with how the prime
minister dealt with proceedings
conservative party leaders and the
truckers themselves also had a majority
disproving of their handling of the
situation but when it comes to how the
protests in ottawa came to an end the
majority of canadians nearly six in ten
saying they believe they were dealt with
in the best possible way given the
circumstances so when we take a look at
the prime minister's
approval in terms of how people believe
he actually handled this protest only 43
percent actually approve of his
performance which is only seven points
ahead of what the uh the public thinks
about how the truckers performed during
this
uh to during the protest which was 36
percent so
not especially a strong performance here
from the prime minister but what's
particularly worrying is that 52 of the
people that we interviewed said that the
prime minister's divisive rhetoric and
the way that he approached the protest
was
mostly responsible for what happened now
they also looked at other things as
being mostly responsible but it was
really surprising to see that level of
animosity among the public about how the
the prime minister characterized what
was going on with this protest the
surprising part for me is while the
truckers don't do
you know don't score in the majorities
on most things you know 46 percent of
the people that we interviewed said that
while they not may not agree with the
tactics they they actually uh sympathize
with the frustration that's being uh
expressed through this and and what's
interesting about that is that um that's
exactly the same number that we had in
our polling about two weeks ago so as
bad as things got during the course of
the the protest it really didn't affect
how people felt about the protesters
themselves which was surprising
and also when you look at the degree of
of sympathy that exists for example like
on economic issues and and the degree
which people are frustrated by that
about 48 percent of the people that we
interviewed said that this protest
probably wouldn't have taken place if
people weren't feeling the level of
economic frustration that they're
feeling
and finally on this point uh 54 of the
people we interviewed actually agree
that that the uh the fact that we're uh
reducing or loosening some of the
coveted restrictions can be attributed
to uh to the fact that these protests
took place so uh the issue here is that
uh even though uh authorities may not
like it uh what what they're seeing uh
from the response from the public is
actually what the what the the
protesters were doing had a certain
amount of sympathy among the canadian
population close to half of the people
we interviewed and on top of that that
it was effective uh 54 said it at least
had some contributing effect on whether
or not we would be loosening the coveted
restrictions the prime minister's had a
series of choices to make about how he's
wanted to characterize
people through the course of this uh
through the course of this pandemic and
he he chose a particular path during the
election campaign and once he got out of
the election campaign he kept right on
that path and characterized the people
who were part of this protest as being
like the the people that he was
criticizing during the election campaign
now arguably he was talking about people
who are voting uh for uh the opposition
parties particularly the people's party
but also the conservative party he took
exactly that same tack through the
course of this uh uh through the course
of this protest and preferred to see uh
the people who were protesting in those
types of partisan terms and what we're
seeing in in these data is not that um
it's not that people are particularly
united around any sort of partisan
choice this is really
a group of the population you know
roughly 40 percent sometimes a bit more
than that sometimes a bit less than that
who really are feeling left out left
behind and very concerned about the way
that the the government's not only
managing the pandemic but also the way
that uh the economy is going right now
and really they have a very challenged
sense of hope but it's not defined in
partisan terms the prime minister chose
to define it in those terms and the
reaction from the public to that has
been quite negative as we've seen in the
in the polling results 52 of the
population saying he added fuel to the
fire so if people are looking at winning
winners and losers in this there doesn't
seem to be any winners at all uh the
truckers at best uh opinion divided uh
usually losing a 60-40 battle maybe 40
percent of the population being aligned
with them but
not particularly winning the prime
minister's performance not seen as
particularly good in fact everybody
provincial premiers the the opposition
parties the conservative party not doing
particularly well through this at all so
there really are no winners in in
anything that uh that happened during
this protest this is the most divided
and frustrated i can ever remember
seeing canadian public opinion and it
doesn't seem that there's any leadership
on the horizon either in any of the
major opposition parties the
conservatives the ndp but particularly
among in the government where people
would most expect to find leadership
that is making this situation better
so we come out of this uh this series of
protests as a very divided uh unstable
uh country in terms of how the public is
feeling about things right now and one
is looking for signs of hope in the data
and we're just not seeing it